we're used to seeing people queuing at
vaccine centers like this but could we
soon be seeing children waiting in line
too
the scientists who advise the government
on vaccinations don't think so but
ministers have asked medical experts to
look again
their focus will be on the impact to
wider society which some believe is the
priority
the jcbi considers the risk benefit of
the vaccine alone for that age group
alone the broader societal and broader
community aspects of the question i
think will be this will be considered by
by
the chief medical officer and the health
minister an appropriate decision
but the joint committee on vaccines and
immunisation which only looked at health
benefits so the picture is very finely
balanced and that benefits to the rest
of society are highly uncertain given
our current understanding of the impact
of vaccination on transmission in the
short and medium term
others argue that long covered is a good
enough reason alone to be vaccinatingly
young
11 000 children
have had long covert for more than a
year and that's not trivial having 11
000 children develop persistent disease
for more than a year and you can talk
about the hypothetical future harms of
vaccines very few vaccines have
long-term effects shown after three to
four months and myocarditis which is the
only complication that has been found so
far is very very rare at a rate of about
30 to 40 per million and happens in the
first week so there's no reason to think
that their long-term effects we know
there are long-term effects from covet
though and we know they can be severe
many children so the direct benefit to
children far outweighs the risk
alongside the row over science there are
big moral questions too which parents
will have to grapple with
we need to start vaccinating the rest of
the world
and i think that's more important at the
moment i just feel like everyone should
be vaccinated
i'd actually like to the best way
forward that's it yeah i'm fully
vaccinated i feel safer if i had
children i'd want them to be vaccinated
the decision is now in the hands of
scientists who are expected to report
back next week but will parents watching
the divide growing over whether
vaccinating children is right or wrong
be willing to support it when it comes
kate mccann sky news